- C'est une transformation
- La Société de l'assurance
automobile du Québec amorce
un virage numérique. Plusieurs
services et documents seront
bientôt offerts en ligne
Par exemple, on pourra u u u u s
de conduire, transférer une
propriété lors de  v vente d'un
véhicule, obtenir son dossier
de conduite ou encore faire
une autodéclarmememememememememG
de la SAAQ, il était temps.
DENIS MAOLOLAIS, président-
directeur général, SAAQ
- Oui, ça a pris du temps,
mais
prendre pour faire bien
- L'objectif est de donner
plus d'autonomie aux clients
et surtout de limiter
les déplacements
dans les succursales.ttttttttttt
qu'il a toujours été très long.
Peut-êununune heure, une heure
et demie, tout le temps.
- Donc, pouvoir le faire
en luiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiuiu.
- Oui. Oui, vraiment pratique,
c'sssûr, parce qu'on court
tout le temps après notre temps.
vont demeurer ouverts,
mais les employés
y seront moins nombreux.
- Moi, je suis quelqu'un qui
n'est pas nécessairement habile
Ça fait que moi,
ça me rend service de venir ici.
- Ceux qui sont habitués et qui
sont à l'aise avec ça, parfa
à l'aise, à ce moment-là, qu'ils
gardent quand même le service.
demandera un grand
déménagement : 10 milliards de
données devront être converties.
La
de transition de trois semaines.
Du 2ieieieier au 16 février,
ieieieieieieieieieieieieieieieie
le remplacement d'un permis
perdu ou volé, seront maintenus.
JEAN-PHILIPPE McKENZIE, VP à
l'accès sécur. au réseauerererer
- Les services qu'on va
continuer à offrir pendant cette
période-là, on va anananananana.
Donc, sans technologie.
- À partir vrvrvrvrvrier,
le service en ligne
mais en période de rodage.
- On duxuxuxuxux clients
d'être patients pendant
cette ererererererererererereree
a coûté 458 millions de dollars
à la société d'État, qui espère
va aussi l'aider à pallier
la pénurie de main-d'oeuvre.
Ici Camille Carpentier,
Radio-Canada, Québe